a Soviet era t-72 rumbles through the
Woodland A Relic from another time
and as the crew Maneuvers over the
frozen mud they fear this 21st century
conflict will remain a quagmire without
more sophisticated Western tanks
at the beginning of this conflict
military planners debated whether the
time of the tank was over but this is a
ground war
the line of contact extending for
hundreds of miles
smoke from artillery strikes scars The
Horizon
we were taken to a front line position
where Rusty old tanks mainly donated by
Eastern European countries lurk in the
trees
foreign
they are still lethal
but in the face of sustained Russian
aggression there's simply no match
we're just outside the city of Bak moot
it's a couple of kilometers that way the
Russians are not much further away now
we're not going to show you the Horizon
because we don't want to give away this
position where the ukrainians are
but they worry that if a new offensive
starts as expected in a couple of months
time without more modern equipment they
won't be able to hold their line
Keith can't understand the reluctance by
some countries to send tanks it argues
they'd give its forces greater mobility
in a conflict that's become defined by
trench warfare
um
foreign
this is about much more than simply
holding position
Vladimir Putin claims a Russian Victory
is inevitable
but Ukraine says with the right
equipment it can do far more than hold
Moscow back it can keep pushing forward
and win this war
Alex Rossi Sky News near back movements